[Musik]
der bart spielt seit jeher eine zentrale
rolle im erscheinungsbild des mannes und
ist ein ausdruck der persönlichen
individualität jeder kennt die filmszene
in denen sich ein kleiner junge freute
sich zum ersten mal zu rasieren und sich
dadurch erwachsen fühlt doch schon die
frauen trugen einen zeremonie albat als
ausdruck ihrer männlichen um die potenz
und das selbst wenn sie frauen war die
bedeutung des bartes hat sich
mittlerweile geändert aber auch heute
decken männer mit dem richtigen bad
attraktiver so zumindest eine studie der
university of queensland 2015
er war wie er war eine zentrale funktion
in der gesellschaft und hat schon im
antiken rom die senatoren in salou
zusammengebracht im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert statt dieses berufsbild
wahrscheinlich durch leichter werden der
apparaturen und besser wenn eine technik
aus doch seit den 2010er jahren erlebt
dieses handwerk auch in deutschland eine
renaissance ein guter was verändert wie
wir uns fühlen und wahrgenommen werden
deswegen meist errichten dieser woche
die hohe kunst des barbier handwerks
dieses video wird unterstützt von braun
ich habe für dieses video drei
freiwilligen deren werte bei mir dran
glauben müssen aber um nicht komplett
ohne vorbereitung an die sache
heranzugehen suche ich im internet nach
einem trainings kopf parat
ich weiß nicht ob ich lachen oder weinen
soll
aber die lieferungen sie leider viel zu
spät die brauchen alle zwei wochen bis
die da sind
der konnte rechtzeitig bevor es losgeht
muss ich mich erst mal inspirieren
lassen und schauen was überhaupt so geht
man warum denn
ich hoffe ich meinen freiwilligen nicht
an ich glaube wir schauen uns mal jemand
ihr böse beispiel wo es sowas kann man
auch machen ist glaube ich die woche
nicht um sowas zu lernen also ihr könnt
aber schon so ein kranker bösewicht in
so einem heftigen kino drin sein
ich glaube aber nicht dass ich meine
freiwillige option weil einlassen würden
deswegen so wie ich mir niemals richtig
cooles raus also sohn vollbart wenn ich
zum beispiel richtig cool auch ihr sohn
gestürzt arbeit kann ziemlich cool
aussehen also ein schnauze steht meiner
meinung nach wirklich niemand
zu schön
[Musik]
aber diese meinung vertritt auch nicht
jeder denn wie meine recherchen ergaben
ist der muss für 14 der männer sogar der
lieblings bad und damit auf platz drei
der beliebtesten werte auf platz 2 der
vollbart mit 18 prozent und ungeschlagen
mit 33 prozent der drei-tage-bart der
bart der aus eigener erfahrung in jeder
fühlt sich lehrer deutschlands trägt
kommt immerhin auf platz 4 mit 8 prozent
aber natürlich nützt die schönste bart
person nichts wenn die ausführung nicht
stimmt für das nötige know-how
recherchiere ich also die
ausbildungsinhalte eines bieres und
finde heraus dass der barbier in
deutschland überraschenderweise gar kein
ausbildungsberuf ist also muss ich auf
eigene faust profis finden die ihr
wissen mit der öffentlichkeit teilen und
es aufsaugen
ok ich glaube ich bin ready zum fange
ich mache lieber mit mir an weil ganz
ehrlich ich bin seit dem umzug nicht
dazu gekommen mich zu rasieren
wo ist meine rasierer brown hat mich für
dieses video mit profi equipment
ausgestattet und damit werde ich erst
mal glatt rasiert kleiner fun fact wenn
man die atra surin google eingibt ist
das erste ergebnis glatt rasur fortnight
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so und jetzt absolute highlight ist
angekommen wird immer jemanden kopf per
post geschickt
das ist übrigens echt hahne
das ist so creepy das ist das coolste
was ich jemals in meinem leben gemacht
habe
wir machen kurz die rollläden runter
nicht dass ich immer in die polizei ruft
hilft mir jetzt mal vorstellen dass es
mal eine menschentraube
das ist so geil dass ich mit dem er
selber machen kann was ich will ich kann
in jeden ball verpassen einfach er muss
also ich würde vorschlagen ich probier
mal den garibaldi
[Musik]
ok also jetzt sieht es zumindest schon
mal aus wie ein richtiger barth und da
gehen wir mal ran im thema
[Musik]
unser erstes testobjekte fühlst du dich
alles klar
jetzt geht ein heiligtum nicht im plan
was ich mache was ich will vorschlagen
wir gerade hier links auf jeden fall
hier unten müssen wir mit dem kameramann
gehen auf eine zwei zentimeter zu kurz
das wird dass wir ganz wunderbar kenne
ich ihn war das mal alles so wunderbar
ok dann wird das gericht erst mal ernst
der blutdruck stark ja wohl fühlst du
dich heute die kompetenz nicht
ausstrahlen schon beruhigt geht am
anfang nervös aber ich bin da geboren
dabei wir sind schon wirklich als
welchen seinen salon dank den 39
verschiedenen längen einstellungen wird
selbst elias massiver bad mit der
lebenslangen schaffen voll mit hall
klinge das bei 7.240 schon ab dem ersten
zug millimetergenau getrennt einfache
feinschliff
[Musik]
so wir sind fertig mehr wenn ich ihn gar
nicht wegnehmen von seiner pracht finde
ich gut jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was
er dazu sagt und er sich jetzt erstmal
bin ich auch gut dass wir unseren ersten
kunden hier frieden bringen konnten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir schauen uns den frischen kopf damit
auch den letzten unsicherheit in den
nächsten kandidaten ausgebügelt werden
mal ganz kurz heftige metal-musik
einblenden
stark dieses mal wenn ich die friendly
matten jobs cool
dafür kommen das kind weg und der rest
bleibt auf einen ordentlichen länger da
wird es erstmal auch nicht getrennt
[Musik]
ich fühle mich ein bisschen wie ein bild
aber da so rein meister der richtige
form raus kreiert ich mal überall stabil
getrimmt und rasierte screen raus jawohl
[Musik]
wenn wir unser nächstes
versuchskaninchen wie hast du so viel an
also wir fangen erst mal an indem wir
deine haare stutzen und danach richtig
aufgeht rasieren ja wie glas wasser
anbieten
das beste bier das gibt trinkgeld pakets
wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht so viel
angst jetzt wie als sich elia rasiert
hatte es ist so viel angenehmer als 100
plastikpuppe zu gast jawohl
mir ist es so zum ersten mal von einem
anderen taxi zu werden jetzt wird die
tat vollbracht und zwar mit dem braun
series 5 damit den neuen ergonomischen
griff schlanker ist und jetzt noch
besser in der hand liegt der kopf passt
sich durch die drei flexiblen klingen
ideal an der gesichts kultur unseres
zweiten bier kunden an
wir haben jetzt ein service hier kannst
du dich gerne mal einmal säubern und das
kann ich schon gesagt hast du jetzt
nicht gleich zum ersten mal seit über
einem jahr mal glatt rasiert sehen wirst
okay bin gespannt wo gott nicht jünger
ich bin da steht ja wieder ein
zufriedener kunde dann geht's ab
zunächst
[Musik]
also wir haben wir wieder zahlende
kundschaft den josef
natürlich war das business aufgebaut
dass er kann's also hier ist wirklich
heftig weil er hat halt einen fetten
waldmann das habe ich noch gar nicht
gesehen bis hierher gekommen ist dass er
so dicht ist auch wir machen auf jeden
fall trotz noch ein vollbad aber halt
schon deutlich kürzer ist schon fast ein
bisschen mehr aber auch irgendwie geil
also ich versuche dir deine ein bisschen
zu erhalten
deswegen will ich hierfür nicht wie
geplant den drei tage war immer auch
satt sondern bediene mich an einem
meiner anderen insgesamt fünf aufsetzen
des braun series fall rasierers und
wähle zuerst sieben millimeter
[Applaus]
wenn wir nochmal eine stufe runter und
das geschieht mit der seitdem braun sind
wir fünf verfügbaren easy click funktion
im handumdrehen das war ganz wunderbar
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt wirklich schon gewonnen
also ich finde die richtig gut und jetzt
hast du echt gut danke wenn der erste
das musst du hier so die runden gemacht
habe und dass auch sie wieder glücklich
wieder den zufriedenen kunden jetzt
wissen es läuft
sonntag 6 ich als erfolgreicher profi
bei ihr habt ja auch nur eine
fünf-tage-woche und nehme erst mal
wochenende obwohl ich das thema schon am
anfang mega spannend fand habe ich erst
im laufe des experiments realisiert wie
heftig der unterschied ist eben bad oder
eben kein wald machen kann so ein bad
oder halt seine abwesenheit kann
erscheinungsbild in der komplett andere
richtung lenken
und ich habe auch gelernt was dazugehört
um als barbier erste richtig gute rasur
zu bieten aber zweitens war auch ein
richtig tolles rasur erlebnis für den
gast zu bieten und auch das ist als
anfänger ganz schön unangenehm sein kann
einen anderen typen zu rasieren aber was
für mich noch relativ ungewohnten rat
das ist bei einem profi bei wir eine
richtig coole zeremonie aus einer
subkultur in der man sich als gentleman
versteht die ganze woche hat mir der
braun series falk und der bat trainer
7240 zur seite gestanden und dann möchte
ich mich an dieser stelle auch einmal
gerne bedanken dass brown diesen relativ
aufwändigen konnte den ich er woche für
woche produziert so unterstützt die
jungs und mädels von brown möchte
natürlich dass ich euch mein
lieblingslied des braun series fall
vorstellt und das ist die risiken
funktion es gibt einfach wirklich nichts
ekliges also wenn sich beim rasieren die
haare da drin verstopfung man ihn nicht
rauskriegt und hier kriegt man es sofort
raus in dem das wasser einmal von allen
seiten wikinger durchführen kann aber
was ich persönlich wirklich ein kurs zu
finden ist dass frauen unternehmen ist
das auch langweiligkeit und qualität
setzt gerade deshalb wohl jeder ist ein
handy wahrscheinlich alle zwei jahre an
bord wirft und sich neues wollt wenn ich
es cool wenn sich im unternehmen wir
geht dafür stark macht produkte
möglichst lang haltbar zu machen uns
hier auf möglichst langen zu nutzen für
dieses video habe ich natürlich den hier
bekommen aber ich habe natürlich auch
den mittlerweile wieder gefunden und das
ist der erste richtige rasierter den ich
mir mit 17 schon gekauft habe einfach
weil mein vater den auftrag hat und der
hat sein jetzt schon seit keiner an
gefühlen die produkte sind eingebaut für
ein leben und das find ich halt das ist
eine ziemlich coole firmenphilosophie in
diesem video gegen sehr viel und es ist
natürlich auch überhaupt nicht stimme
man kaum bartwuchs hat obwohl ich mich
jetzt schon so ein bisschen froh wieder
mir mal einen drei tage bart stehen zu
lassen
der link zu bauen ist in dem video
beschreibung wenn ihr wissen wollt als
nächste woche für ein video kommt freut
mich denn auf instagram der poste ich
meins soll dies schon immer was von dem
video bevor sie überhaupt online kommt
und auch was von der neuen wohnung wenn
ich auf dieser reise begleiten möchten
diesen kanal unternehmen zum nächsten
wie das macht
[Musik]